Earlier in lesson three,
we referred to PKI indirect.
This is another highly simplified
representation of direct designed
specifically to show the dual function
these keys play in security and trust.
Along the top, you see that
the message attachment, which contains
protected information, is encrypted
using the receiver's public key.
This is a critical point.
Anyone can discover their intended
recipient's public key and
can use it to secure information they
wish to send to the owner of that key.
Since only the owner should
have the matching private key,
only they can decrypt and
view the message.
That's the essence of PKI for security.